and tonight as you heard from brett the
biden policy uh crime wave continues
unabated we're going to get into the
christmas tree shortly democratic
rhetoric pushing division and distrust
and is inflicting daily consequences on
all americans as it plows along
targeting you your family and businesses
across the country another example of
the wanton chaos comes to us once again
indeed from new york city when our
all-american christmas tree in the fox
plaza was burned down in the early
morning hours i think it was just a bit
after midnight
we've seen of course also the torching
of small businesses in blue cities we've
watched an abject horror as molotov
cocktails have been tossed into police
cars as antifa and other leftist riders
through liquid concrete into the faces
of journalists and others who would dare
to expose them and their violent tactics
and so now it's a christmas tree the
symbol of unity during the holiday
season but don't worry about us at fox
news though we're fine we are rebuilding
archery uh it will be relit tomorrow and
it will be bigger and more beautiful
than before and our security team is in
fact the best in the business but these
are the benefits of being a major
corporation most americans don't have
this luxury
no one should have to plan their lives
around professional security many of us
here do
the average person though can't walk
around with a bodyguard and all of us
face the impacts of this crime wave
but this is indicative of where our
society indeed is headed under the
carelessness and malevolence of democrat
leadership where crime runs rampant and
you are scared to leave your home fear
is what the democrats want to prevail
they want you to be afraid to live your
life
too afraid to get involved or too afraid
to stand up to them certainly and they
are already failing with that goal
now in chicago mayor lori lightfoot is
blaming the smash and grab lootings in
that city on the stores
she's complaining they're not doing
enough to protect themselves from the
mob
some of the retailers downtown and
michigan avenue i will tell you i'm
disappointed that they're not doing more
to take safety
and make it a priority for example we
still have retailers that won't
institute
plans like having security officers in
their stores making sure
that they've got cameras that are
actually operational
while there's so much to say politicians
continue to create an untenable and
violent environment and then blame the
victim and it's not just about the local
crime waves joe biden's attempts to
trash the constitution with vaccine
mandate after mandate is at least being
thwarted by federal judges for the
menace that they are as a federal
district judge in georgia just this week
blocked biden's vaccine mandate for
federal contractors meaning that nearly
every single biden vaccine mandate has
been blocked nationwide as judge stan
baker wrote in his ruling tuesday
even in times of crisis this court must
preserve the rule of law and ensure that
all branches of government act within
the bounds of their constitutionally
granted authorities isn't that what all
of us have been saying but that doesn't
seem to matter to the village troll
flipper fauci in love with being on tv
as he continues to abandon science and
threatens americans with political
opinions based on guesswork he again
insisted personal freedom is way
overrated and dangerous totalitarian
mandates everybody is the only way to be
safe
when you're in the middle of what we
call a historic experience
of the worst pandemic of a respiratory
disease in the last 100 years
we have to put the communal
responsibility ahead of individual
preferences sometimes you've got to do
things that are unpopular but that
clearly supersede individual choices
wow but of course to the left into the
extreme democratic party the rule of law
the constitution and the separation of
powers is an afterthought because
remember this isn't the first
unconstitutional power grab the
democrats have tried to ram down the
throat of the american public remember
this fall when biden's eviction
moratorium was struck down by the
supreme court after joe biden so much as
admitted it was unlikely the order would
pass legal scrutiny blind power grabs
reckless efforts to infringe on your
personal liberty and individual
sovereignty well it's just another day
in joe biden's washington but thankfully
our judicial branch along with millions
upon millions of common sense americans
are standing up they're standing up
against medical tyranny standing up
against attacks on the separation of
powers and standing up against an agenda
obsessed with trying to regulate every
single aspect of your day-to-day life
all of these things should now be a top
priority for every american now the good
news americans all across the country
are in fact doing this and the coal and
they're coalescing around the idea that
america is a fundamentally good nation
rejecting the radicalism being foisted
upon us by the far left progressive
opposition it's why we see americans
taking to the streets to protest
mandates even willing to lose their jobs
to preserve fundamental principles of
autonomy and freedom of choice and it's
why we see a wave of retirements among
democrats ahead of the 2022 midterms
isn't that funny so what's the democrats
answer to seeking approval
and creator and credibility to fuel more
hysteria more panic and more speculation
about everything in anything covet for
example here in new york the governor
recently declared a state of emergency
and move to halt elective surgeries
despite no evidence that the new omicron
variant is more deadly but actually
evidence to the contrary exists from the
south african epicenter but of course
the worst variant of them all is called
leftism it's hell-bent on grabbing power
attacking individual liberty destroying
our sacred institution so tonight
let's remember to never give up give up
our sovereignty to always preserve our
dignity you know they may think that
burning things down will make them
disappear but like with everything else
they underestimate the american people
and our resolve so the fox christmas
tree like american businesses will be
back and the trees return is the
reminder that the american dream will
not be intimidated or destroyed hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else